take down the fall of the last muffin
Pierre is by New York City police
detective Rick Cowan and reporter
Douglas century it's their account of
the breakup of the Mafia garbage cartel
in the 1990s they spoke at the South
Street Seaport in New York City for
about an hour
good evening and welcome to the South
Street Seaport museums Melville gallery
and our Arts and Letters program it's a
real pleasure tonight to welcome you
here for the first of three events
related to crime in New York City and
it's an especial pleasure to introduce
the first of the three tonight we are
going to have two people who will be
reading from and discussing a book that
they have just spent a couple years
working on it's called take down the
fall of a last mafia empire and it is
about the longest and most successful
investigation of organized crime ever
undertaken by the New York City Police
Department it resulted in 75 condition
convictions and the end of the garbage
mafia cartel that ruled how much people
had to spend to take away private waste
and various companies around the city
the two authors whom I am about to
introduce are people I've both known and
met for a while Doug sentry is someone
I'm very happy to be inviting back to
the second reading I've done with him
and to tell you a little bit about them
first I'll start with Rick Cohen who is
the major investigator on this case and
who will be talking with Douglas after
the reading from the book Rick Cohen is
a 19 year veteran of the New York Police
Department where he remains on active
duty as Detective first grade in the
organized crime investigations division
he is an authority of the Cosa Nostra
and his undercover role in operation
wasteland earned him a personal
promotion from then Police Commissioner
William Bratton Doug sentry is the
author of I'll have to say this a
wonderful book Street Kingdom five years
inside the Franklin Avenue Posse he's a
contributing writer for the New York
Times and his work has appeared in
numerous national magazines and
newspapers please welcome Douglas
century and Rick Cohen
Steve thank you for having us
Rick and I Rick Cowan and I wrote this
book together and I want to give before
Rick comes up and actually before he
actually answers questions and discusses
I'm gonna read some sections of the book
so you get a little little of the flavor
this is the story of an investigation
but it's also Rick's personal story he
was undercover for more than three years
and it was a became ultimately became
the most successful the largest and most
successful takedown of a of a mafia
enterprise in the history of the New
York Police Department in the Manhattan
DA's office but it's not a dry
investigative book it is very much
Rick's personal story and we worked long
and hard to achieve a certain voice some
I would say 80% of the book is in Rick's
and media first-person voice now if you
don't know anything about the garbage
industry I'm sure Rick can explain it
better than I can see was actually there
but you have to understand one thing
about this case the for 50 years almost
the mob ran the garbage cartel in New
York we kind of explained in the book
how that happened but sorry can you hear
me okay in the back if you've watched
mob movies you tend to see things like
prostitution and illegal gambling and
all these you know which have been the
bread and butter of the mob but there
was no industry there was a bigger money
earner for them than garbage we're very
close to the Fulton fish market here
that also was taken down in a big
investigation during the Giuliani
administration that was a 50 million
dollar a year industry the garbage
business was 1.5 billion it wasn't it
dwarfed every other enterprise that the
mob had and generations of law
enforcement had tried to get inside
going back to Robert Kennedy the
McClellan Commission everybody knew that
the might was a it was a kind of joke it
was an open secret into the 80s and 90s
that the mob was running the garbage
industry but people couldn't get inside
it to take it down there was a great
investigation in the 70s the FBI did
arrest a couple people but that was the
that was the problem you could take down
a few people but not the entire
organizational structure and Rick is
gonna tell you when he gets up to answer
the questions how he got inside you
could only do it by fluke it was it was
impossible for law enforcement to really
place a man there and the story it is
stranger than fiction how he gets inside
but to give you a little flavor of how
the book is written I'm gonna read two
short passages that describe what Rick
was going through the first one is the
first time he goes to a mobbed-up
restaurant on the west side of New York
is a place at that time was called Ponty
steakhouse it still exists and Rick is
going undercover I hope Rick will
forgive me for sort of channeling his
voice we're gonna be like a magic team
up here I'm gonna be reading something
in his first-person like Penn & Teller
or something the first time he goes
inside this club he's now been
affiliated with a very legitimate
Brooklyn Italian family named Benedetto
and they're real heroes of the book Rick
has been working in this industry now
briefly but he has never gone to a
restaurant that's been frequented by the
mob wearing a wire and the significant
thing about this case to know is that
they're briefly I'll tell there's two
different devices two different styles
of devices that that detectives and FBI
guys wear one is a body recorder and
it's kind of an interesting theme within
the book how the technology keeps
advancing as the case is going on so in
the early days they have very primitive
large metal boxes that they have to
strap on themselves it called an Agra
later on they have a device called a
jaybird those are body recorders and
that allows him to tape people up close
and personal but they also have a
transmitting device and this scene is
about how he has a problem with the
transmitting device and I'll just begin
to read it so I'm this is Rick is
speaking Rick would probably read this
himself but it's not I don't think it's
part of a detective's job description to
be doing literary readings he's marking
he's become an old hand at answering
questions about the case so this was the
first meeting at Ponte steakhouse in
1992 it was a Christmas party I decided
to strap on both an Agri and a Kel
that night at Pontes no matter how
carefully you prepare there are always
technical problems you lose parts of
conversations get squawks and static and
dead spots and I was so keyed up going
to pontes I didn't want to lose anything
we were going to a combination Christmas
party and meeting of the New York
Association of paper mills dealers and
suppliers Sal now Sal is the the man who
has let Rick work and his company cell
is a legitimate businessman and he's
basically vouching for Rexach real hero
of the book named Sal Benedetto Sal was
on the board of directors it was the
only Association that the Benedetto's
belonged to a legitimate group that met
every few months to exchange new
information about the industry and gave
real paper dealers a chance to network
it was at Ponti's that night that I
first saw the whole landscape it was a
perfect night to observe Angelo and his
double life there was a legitimate paper
people in meeting in one room and then
in the back room playing poker there
were all the wise guys like Joe Franco
lino and Ali shades the hoods would come
out from their card game to troll around
the bar puffing cigars looking to put
the arm on legit guys Sal threw a little
Chum in the water standing at the bar
with an ear shot of a couple of his
friends he muttered that I was his
cousin Danny just coming into the paper
business from Dom Ben Realty and I was
introduced to several key industry
players the paper mill Association had
booked a whole room filled with round
tables we had to go around in turn
introduce ourselves that was the first
time I had to stand up in public and say
hi my name is Dan Benedetto I'm the
manager of chambers paper fibers in
Brooklyn man was I in over my head some
expert was up there giving a big lecture
about the economics of overseas shipping
complicated financial stuff and I turned
to one of the guys next to me I don't
understand what the hell he's talking
about I'm down in the transfer station
I'm dealing with trucks and customers he
was an older guy from the Midwest he
shrugged at me whispering you know
something my friend I don't understand
it either I'm not in that end of the
business which made me feel like less of
an idiot about halfway through the
meeting I noticed I was having a problem
in my pants
I'd wrapped the transmitter in metal
gauze made him sorry in medical gauze
and that and then surgical taped it to
my crotch inside my shorts later on in
the case I got more sophisticated with
this stuff I was shave first and use a
cutoff tube sock to wrap the Calla
but that first night in Pontes it was so
hot and my nerves were making me so
sweaty that I suddenly felt the quell
transmitter starting to shift and slide
out of position oh when I could ease any
vulgarity this this is a little graphic
it had suddenly come loose from the tape
and was now pressing directly against my
skin there's a 3 watt transmitter in
there and after a while it started to
get hot really burning me I had to be
careful getting up because I was afraid
it was gonna fall clear out of my pants
slide right down the pant leg as I
passed all the wise guys smoking stogies
at the bar I had to get up very gingerly
and start limping towards the bathroom
the coast looked clear but as I ducked
into the men's room I got that feeling
of someone coming up close behind me and
when I glanced back I almost crapped my
pants it was Joe Franco Leno if there's
one guy in the world I didn't want
catching me with my pants down it was
Joe Frankel II know they call him Joey
cigars John Gotti's hand-picked guy
actually at that unpleasant moment in
Pontes I really didn't know much about
him besides the fact that he was a
fast-rising wise guy in the Gambino
crime family we knew he was the number
two guy in the Gambino garbage Club
being groomed by gaudí to take over from
old Jimmy Brown we knew he owned a big
company on 19th Street called Duffy
waste removal I had been checking with
our NYPD intelligence desk Gambino
section but they didn't have much else
he had never been arrested in his life
not even for something minor which was
unusual unusual for a gangster who'd
been on the scene for quite a while even
the FBI didn't have much on Joe the one
thing the feds did know from their
secret tapes made in the apartment above
the ravenite social club was that God he
talked about him quite a bit
they had gaudí on tape saying he
personally inducted Joey into the
Borgata after they hit on boss pasta
Paul Castellano
there were many guys in the Gambino
family still faithful to big Paul and
Jimmy Brown was one of them but Joe
Franco lino was considered a true-blue
Gotti loyalist he dressed flashy walked
with a strut just like John coming down
Mulberry Street that night at Pontes he
had on a $3,000 Italian suit gold
cufflinks silk tie there were fat
diamond pinkie ring flashing on one hand
and a and a freshly lit cigar between
his teeth Joe was in his mid-50s and he
wore his thinning hair
these short curly bangs a little like
Julius Caesar it was a very intimidating
presence to be alone with I thought not
the tallest guy in the world maybe a
shade under six feet but he had the most
intense stare in his blue gray eyes and
the broken boxers nose that let you know
he was no fake tough guy tonight we were
alone in the men's room together and Joe
started unzipping I made a beeline for
the stalls the pain in my crotch was
excruciating I couldn't wait to pry the
burning quel device off my skin but the
whole time Frank Alena was taken his
time lurking right outside the stall and
I didn't dare start stripping off the
surgical tape I don't know what Tony
Maserati and the rest of the field team
actually heard some rustling maybe some
breathing it's really not something they
can prepare you for in the police
academy how to sit on the crapper remove
a Kel transmitter from your package
without making a sound while a gangster
is standing three feet away from you
taking a leak at last I heard Joe
leaving the bathroom and I started to
tear off the surgical tape with a little
adjustment I got the kill transmitter
back in position and made it out of the
bathroom it was a small miracle that I
never raised anybody up I came back into
the papermill Association meeting took
my seat next to Sal and Johnny 2zo still
struggling to understand the lecture in
progress but after my encounter after my
encounter with Joe Franco Leo I found
myself even more distracted for the rest
of the night I kept glancing back at the
bar
where Joe and Ally shades and the other
flashy mob guys were laughing and
bellowing over their martinis and cigars
I hope that someday with a little luck
I'd be standing there in the clouds of
cigar smoke laughing it up with them
well what happens in the case is that
Rick does as playing the role of Danny
Benedetto he goes inside these clubs the
mob exerted this incredible influence
over this industry through these these
are trade associations they also control
the unions so it was a perfect criminal
monopoly and you know since we have a we
have the actual real McCoy here I'm not
gonna read much more but setting up that
scene he has this encounter with Joe
Frankel II know there's a great irony in
the book is that the same man becomes
something of his protector this very
powerful Gambino soldier very fearsome
guy I mean you have to read the book to
see how that happens but bit by bit over
the course of many many years Rick gets
closer and closer to the power of these
really these mob
you know first it's just connected guys
not inducted members in the Mafia but
then ultimately he gets very close to
this Joe Franklin lino and I don't see
Tony here yet but I was gonna read a
funny part of the book that had to do
with Tony do you see Tony okay
good security Tony's providing right now
this this is towards the end of the book
Rick has spent now years ingratiating
himself getting to know these powerful
mobsters and he's just gone to a
Christmas party he began the entire
investigation before he was even
undercover doing surveillance on a very
powerful Genovese captain capo regime
named Alphonse Ali shades melon gone and
at this point the case is almost the
case is going along so well that he
knows he's pretty soon he's gonna be
coming out from the undercover role and
he's he's able to let loose he's now
really transformed himself into this
person that he was claiming to be and
he's at a Christmas party at Ali's Club
and the one thing to know about this
scene is that now Joe Frankel II know
that gangster that he had the run-in
with has now really become his his
protector in the industry that night at
Ali's Club I had noticed guys like Carl
Bivona slipping envelopes to Frank to
give to Ally I knew you were expected to
take care of the big wiseguys at
Christmastime like Joe Franco lino said
a birthdays and Christmas I ain't
allergic to green I came by the Gambino
club and asked Pattie pecker arrow what
I should do about Joey's Christmas tip
I'm gonna be Danny Claus this year I
said Danny Claus patty laughs nodding
rubbing his thumb and fingers together I
picked out a nice Christmas card for Joe
and slipped five crisp C notes inside I
also got him a big box of his favorite
cigars just before the holiday we had a
we had dinner at Peter Reno's on Reed
Street it was a fine night of pasta and
red wine and bid-rigging
we were scheming to rig the bid for the
Walbaum supermarket chain at the end of
the night we paused in the vestibule to
say goodbye Joe I said I just want to
thank you for everything you've done for
me and my family we do appreciate it
I want to wish you and your family a
nice holiday then I gave him a big box
of Tiamo Toro cigars
ah thanks Danny Joe said then we kissed
each other on the cheeks of course the
kiss between two men is fairly common in
Italian culture but among wiseguys it's
truly a gesture of respect every
Wednesday night John
God he loved to stand outside the
ravenite on Mulberry Street accepting
the kisses of guys like Jimmy Brown and
Joey Frankel II know my point man on
surveillance that night was Bobbie
O'Donoghue who's not a cop he's an
investigator in the DA's office Bobby
was parked close by operating the quell
booster keeping a careful eye on me
Bobby was a typical conservative Irish
Catholic from Queens and he often said
there's only two times in your life when
you touch another man that's when you're
shaking his hand and when you're
knocking him out Bobby was in the
unmarked car with the Kel booster and
when he saw Joe and me embracing and
kissing he started broadcasting over the
radio to the rest of the field team
Jesus he won't believe what just
happened
Danny's in the foyer with Franco lino
and Franco you know just slipped his
tongue down Danny's throat I'm getting
sick everybody in the surveillance van
burst out laughing and Bobby kept going
on with this it became a source of comic
relief for months throughout the grand
jury testimony and the trial Bobby would
tell everyone the brass the DA's anyone
who would listen I've seen these guys
French kissing each other and then make
a face like he was gonna retch
when I left Pierino is that night I
circled around cleaned myself of any
possible tales then drove down to the
old sailors home below Battery Park City
parked and walked down to the waterfront
in a few minutes Tony Maserati and Bobby
O'Donoghue showed up
Bobby jumped out of the car like it was
on fire hollering Dan you're letting me
down you're grossing me out
what are you doing wetting frankly no
slip his tongue in your mouth even Tony
maws was getting in on the act you two
frigging lovebirds but Tony and Bobby
both knew that this was our best night
yet a great conspiracy captured on tape
ending with a sign that I had fully
become one of the big boys we're now
greeting in the most intimate mob
fashion
Joey cigars doesn't go around kissing
just anybody okay so that's a little
flavor of how the book is written but I
want to now open it up and have you
actually talked to the man himself
because he's here and I'll moderate but
I I mean if anybody has any more general
questions about the industry or the the
role the investigation because Ric was
the key undercover in this investigation
but the investigation was a massive
undertaking and you know it takes 352
pages of the book to really get a sense
of the scope of this investigation but
at the at this point I think we should
just open it up to anybody's kind of
first question already okay well we have
to bring a mic okay okay sorry I I got
one sense of the evil of the situation
of garbage being controlled by garbage
when I learned from a friend with a very
small architectural firm and the garbage
that they generated in the course of the
day was maybe to paper coffee cups and
they were in a commercial building and
they were told that they were you know
going to have to take on this particular
service I don't know my own my
contracting store whatever it was and
the the contractor at first didn't
identify his affiliation and then walked
the young architect up to the roof and
said you see how far down it is to the
street well I obviously shakedown is one
way in which this the Mafia controlling
the industry creates a problem for doing
business but what were the other aspects
that impinged on clean society by having
the Mafia control garbage well just
before I passed over to Rick I mean that
is actually a common that's something we
hear about a lot in the book and it's a
common story you hear everybody so you
understand how the mob controlled this
industry there was no competition they
did it was a cartel system it was a
perfect monopoly because they controlled
the Union and they control the the
companies and if anybody complain about
their garbage they would not get first
of all the simplest things they wouldn't
get anybody to give him a fair
competitive rate but if they really made
waves like your friend found out I mean
these guys were it was one of the you
know most rough-and-tumble industries
around and murder they established their
rule in the 50s of murdering anybody who
competed so after a while it was like a
joke you didn't have to compete you
didn't have to even tell I mean what
your friend experienced I'm sure Rick
will tell you is probably they didn't
most times they didn't even need to go
that far but at this point now that
we've had the first question I'm gonna
pass it over to Rick and he is the the
expert on all things relating to the
garbage and certainly this case those
stories are a thousand they're a dime a
dozen very confusing but when I was
running the conventional
as a detective in charge of the team
into the garbage industry we heard of
all these stories but nobody would dare
talk to a cop you come in you'd ask them
to relate their story and they turn your
back they're back on you the only way to
really penetrate the case and to see
from the the inside in looking out was
to get in with an undercover there have
been many undercover operations the FBI
the County local state all different
agencies were doing this they would set
up a company and the mob the way they
were way to mouth it was a closed
industry like the Mafia itself
they were very clannish they were
predominantly Italian run businesses
they were passed down from grandfathers
that their sons and their grandsons so
those are very close community community
everyone knew everybody and made it very
difficult to penetrate there were
several layers that board members that
presence of these clubs so to speak and
behind these clubs there was a wiseguy
there was the wiseguys job to enforce it
but very few people ever even got to the
the powers to be in these associations
if they were suspect of a particular
company they were just way to mount they
know law enforcement can fund an
operation indefinitely they would wait a
year if they had to let him think a few
stops and when they got no evidence of
criminal wrongdoing they would go on
their way and they were more right back
in their tactics were very shrewd
sometimes they would make things look
legitimate if they really felt the
customer these big powerful companies
thought something was up they would put
it out to bid and they would orchestrate
it where it looked legitimate they would
have the guys in the club that would
approach the incumbent Carter and say
look your your customers approached us
they're bringing out the bid and they
will go in with higher bids than the
incumbent make it all look legitimate
and the make look like they really were
getting that amount of garbage coming
out like you're for another two cups
they probably had a little bit more than
that but city regulations also tells
every commercial establishment in this
city they have to
hire a private Carter for their
commercial refuse so that they're
between a rock and a hard place
some of the governors are so minimal
zine even worth picking up or charging
these people but leave me these people
would charge them through the nose if
they didn't the mob would call city
sanitation report them that they didn't
have a Carter and they you dealing with
the one tough guy and then you deal with
the city agency giving you a summons you
didn't have a Carter or there was a mess
out in front of your place the mess
wasn't put out there by the customer it
was about the gorsh man in the middle
mighty was leaving debris all over the
place and you know blaming it on the
customer so they had a thousand tactics
to hold these people hostage like they
didn't so and until 1956 when people
didn't get the message they resorted to
violence and they were very good at it
these guys that were carrying out these
tough-guy tactics were professionals the
guys that ran the industry were not just
street thugs they were well
sophisticated hardcore members of a
mafia like I said before the guys behind
the scenes were all made members of the
mafia and divided up between the two
most powerful families in the country
the Gambino family headed by John Gotti
and the Genovese family headed by
Vincent the chin Gigante it was that
system that I was able to penetrate on a
complete lard we had a conventional case
going we had bugs we had wires we were
listening to a lot of people we knew who
were the powers-that-be in this city we
knew who the guys were controlling it
but proving it in court was another
another hurdle how it all started was we
got wind of a fire bombing of a garbage
truck on the Brooklyn waterfront I
called the guy up on a Friday this Sal
Benedetto and he blew me off so I
thought were just another just another
dead end but trying to make something
out of nothing I called them on Monday
and I said if he could just give me five
minutes of his time I like to talk to
him and to my surprise he said yeah come
on down so I wanted to see him and I
walked into this huge old transfer say
first I got lost going there the great
detective I got along I came to find the
damn place
I got lost ended up in Manhattan twice
it was a big it was embarrassing but I
eventually found the place and there was
a big old-fashioned building cobblestone
streets real old old New York I went
into this place and I met a very big
heavyset guy fast-talking and as big as
he was he was a fast moving character
south Benedetto and I never heard about
him I didn't know who he was I was
careful with this guy because I really
wasn't sure he was part of the fold or
not so ten minutes into the interview
his shop foreman came barging in and
said Sal I'm starting throw up but the
guys that blew up the truck just drove
by My partner and I think we had an
unbelievable breakthrough that we could
actually maybe go out get a license
plate and possibly make an arrest I got
up I ran out with my partner behind me
the owner behind him and the manager
behind him it was a whole LAN light it
was going out the front door as we went
out the front door unbeknownst to us the
guys were the two thugs were coming in
and the first thing I saw was two guys
one large guy in front of me and one guy
to the right who had a gun in his pocket
went like this
and the second guy was Bullock a
heavyweight fighter put his fist to my
face and we had a very violent
confrontation where I thought any second
they're gonna shot was gonna be fired
and though someone was gonna be shot the
only thing I had to do was to try and
defuse the situation I had been in
undercover before cops do this every day
out and just with disputes at all so
this was just you know matter of the
matter of course so I tried to calm it
down and in doing so I asked the guy who
sent them and he asked me who I was
and without any plan I mean I didn't
know this guy Benedetto he said that's
cousin Dan he works here but I continued
talking a mile a minute if the guy was
they asked me what my name was
a minute later I wouldn't have known it
but we can continue talking and the guy
said this is a serious problem it's not
gonna go away you got until 2 o'clock to
call me at this number there's gonna be
a sit-down and we won't know what your
intentions are so that was a major break
in a case that was not a company like
the previous law enforcement agencies
had done this is a company that had been
around for a hundred years and a
well-established company well-known
company and a company that had been from
Krakow Italy where a lot of these
garbage men had
I'm from some of the prominent quarters
in the city paper guys and garbage guys
Ponte was a garbage guy and paper guy
there are other guys that were garbage
people there came for the same town
krakow italy it's a desert type town in
italy like the ones shown in the
Godfather movie this leg we thought this
would be a short-lived case maybe a few
months it led to a few meetings we've
got a bug put in South Benin that has
office we arranged for future meetings
where these guys came down they
threatened us these two thugs and lo and
behold the conventional end of the case
where I was doing conventional detective
work identifying subjects running
eavesdropping phone taps bugs all that
sort of thing all these guys that we
identified as the powers that be in the
city in this industry started coming to
this company legitimate company the sort
of strong-arming him because in the
early 90s the garbage business and the
recycling business clashed heads because
of the city's mandating sewer separation
laws so I was right there at the right
time when these big when the cartel the
mafia machine began putting the Armand
DiBenedetto company I was there and
salbon unease Bennett does with me any
hood they didn't want anything to do
these people they for years avoided them
but now that their energies were
clashing they felt they had no other
choice but then to call the police and
cooperate otherwise sell their company
and they didn't want to do that so this
I was their point man I was Danny
Benedetto and like I said we thought it
would late and to a few a few months we
would get to behind the scenes guy who
send the two thugs down who was very
close to the famous infamous Captain
James Jimmy Brown viola of the Gambino
family and Joe frankly no but when these
cartels from the Bronx and Brooklyn and
Manhattan sort of coming towards us if
the case got much deeper and as the the
undercover role began to take a life of
its own the Dan Benedetto role really
expanded at the Rick Cowan life really
shrank next to nothing and this is how
it went on for
for several years we my wife and I my
wife Claire and I were living on Staten
Island
that's the mob capital of the country
it's like mafia central they're all over
the place so it was difficult to bob and
weave for that long there was a guy that
lived a few doors away in our
condominium who was called Jimmy garbage
and he knew me as Rick he didn't know I
was a company know me as Rick and I was
always worried about going to these
transfer stations other guys companies
and that I would run into him and he
would say he would know me as Rick in
the condo in Staten Island and not dam
Benedetto living in another part of
Staten Island and not bringing a very
large garbage company so it was always a
difficult tightrope to walk but we were
successful the police department really
police resources behind it knowing that
the biggest city in the world greatest
city there is was held hostage by these
hardcore mobsters since 1956 so they
really went at it very aggressively and
that felt there was my job to pursue it
just as aggressively and in the end I'm
proud to say that I was a part of it and
I'm glad that we were able to take this
cartel down we took down the board
members the vice presidents the
presidents and the piece behind the
scenes guys that were the soldiers and
captains or Capo's of the Genovese and
Gambino crime families and I did that by
being extorted by them pressured by all
these these the garbage clubs and became
for the first time and all these years
of all these investigations it was the
first time that a member of law
enforcement became an accepted member of
the Mafia criminal club the enterprise
and that's how we took it down all their
secret ways of bid-rigging all the ways
of camouflaging extortion payments
through dumping bills that were
tax-deductible Uncle Sam had a you know
foot the bill there they had every way
they had they had this thing down to a
science and we took it down 72
indictments and 72 convictions just
before we take a nice question I just
think going back to your original
question I think is one thing Manasseh
like what was the other negative
packed on the city oh yeah well what
would the difference have been for if
someone really did have a lot of garbage
what they were paying this monopoly this
criminal monopoly versus if there had
been a truly open market just one thing
one thing to clarify when this case
after this case happened it was
announced there was they had saved the
city of New York six hundred and forty
million dollars a year
so the overcharging to the consumer of
New York was the mob was charging forty
percent roughly more than it should have
and Giuliani himself I mean this was one
of the biggest accomplishments of his
administration said that this by itself
the mob tax on garbage was contributing
to the cost of living in New York being
much higher than anywhere else in the
country so it had a big negative impact
on everybody that lived in New York and
of course if you had a small business
everybody had to pay an exorbitant rate
so it hit everybody sorry there's a
question in the back from the man in the
white shirt yes hi could you talk a
little about the difference between an
Angelo Ponte who appeared to be a
legitimate businessman and yet at the
same time was able to work very closely
with high-ranking mafiosos this this is
this question for Rick is about a man
named Angelo Ponte that first scene I
read it was a scene in Ponte Steakhouse
Ponte is a very prominent man in the
garbage industry and he was also a big
restaurant owner as well as a real
estate mogul so he he's not in the
newspaper as much but he was one of the
principal targets of this investigation
and Rick got to know him pretty well
Angelo Ponte owns a very large recycling
companies and garbage companies he was
the largest garbage company owner in
this city he's had an or an air of
respect he's a knight of Malta with the
Catholic Church he's one of the starters
of cops shot in the City Police
Department for you know donating in for
rewards for people that shoot cops he's
got this above board law
but really law enforcement has
surveilled his restaurant for many years
decades where high-level members of the
Mafia have gathered and need thinner and
held meetings in his restaurant we knew
he was a power to be reckoned with but
to prove it like I said again you had to
get an F you had to get an undercover
inside to find out the true power
because real Angelo Ponte had another
life he had the above world and he had
the underworld power he could pick up
the phone or go meet in person soldiers
and captains of the very powerful mob
families to us get a beef straightened
out to his liking what I had a very
scary night during undercover role
probably the most scariest incident in
my life
unbeknownst to me there was a there's a
there was a garbage golf outing in Long
Island I chose not to go I'm not a very
good golfer and like I said before I
wanted to avoid certain people that knew
me as Rick possibly so I stayed away but
unknown unknowns to me that a member of
the Benedetto family not knowing
anything about he lived out of state he
was also in the business though so he
came to this golf outing and he was
approached by a couple of connected guys
that I was around and they asked about
your cousin Dan we took him in how's he
doing this and that and he didn't know
he didn't know anything about the N
Benedetto he didn't know anything about
the investigation and he told these
gangsters that I can't think of a damn
Benedetto when the family but I know
there's no damn Benedetto working in the
Brooklyn transfer station these guys
were caught off guard they they backed
up and they asked this guy so what are
you telling us he's an undercover FBI
agent so now this guy knows he stepped
into some serious stuff he sort of
backpedaling he said I don't know what
I'm telling you but I'm not telling you
that he got off the golf course and he
called Sal Benedetto Sal gave him a
story that I was a bastard child of one
of the Benedetto's who had been a priest
in there in the early 60s
he said you know who dan is it was no I
really know what's going on here he goes
you know Robert he said Robert cuz he
knew Robert was a priest
he says yeah you know what that whole
thing with him leaving the priesthood he
goes that's son-of-a-gun that's what's
going on
he said yeah so we had a little very
wacky story but I wasn't sure what I was
going to fly the mob grapevine being
what it is word traveled very quickly I
knew about this very serious breach of
confidentiality as far as the case was
concerned and it took about a week for
the these genevese guys to go back and
get the word back to Joe Frankel II know
the Gambino side of the cartel one night
I was closing up the transfer station I
was alone I got a call it was from Joe
Franco Nino and the Gambino club usually
met on Tuesday afternoons he said Dan
what am I gonna see you so I'll see you
tomorrow at the club he said no I'd like
to see it tonight so I knew that these
guys had gone to him is saying that this
damn Benedetto is not known by an actual
Benedetto my boss Tony Maserati said the
case has gone on long enough
we've got most of the people locked up
we can cut our losses right here but I
felt I've put a lot of time into the
case the whole team did we should at
least give it a shot if we had a walk in
slow maybe we could run out quick if we
had to so I chose to push it to the
limit I had a I had a transmitter on I
was wearing a body recorder most of the
everyone was everyday in the case but if
I was gonna be patted down I thought I
was gonna be you know probably
outnumbered I might be searched so I
figured let me go with a transmitter
with that would not be easily detectable
I gotta tell you frankly no told me
where to park I was unfamiliar with the
restaurant he said that he directed me
to a a paid parking lot and I went in
he's gonna give you a ticket that's it
this guy asked me right away soon as I
pulled in what's your name
so I told him Dan he said go park in the
back way back buddy alley and take it
keys and go up to go up the block so I
knew he probably knew this guy and it
really put a fear put the fear of God
into me as I was walking up the street
to this restaurant Pia Reno's on Reed
Street I
even feel my knees I felt like I was
hovering instead of walking I was just
vision visualizing the worst as I went
into the restaurant I stepped in there
was a big glass vestibule I looked at
the bar there's nobody there I look
looking through the dining room I can
only see half the dining room through
the vestibule I didn't see anybody
sitting there so I kind of felt like
Luca Brasi and the Godfather going to me
that the taggle use when I got that
famous Sicilian that next time that's
how I kind of felt so I said I thought I
had the wrong address I stepped back out
looked at the address after the name Pia
Reno's I got it right I went back in I
saw that the stairs going down to the
basement I walked down there and as I
got to the very bottom of the basement
around from the corner came Joe Franco
lino scared the hell out of me I mean my
stomach was flip-flopping but I tried to
you know my face I tried to cover it up
he asked me how I was doing he was very
casual let's go to the bar have a drink
we talked about a few things that he had
been looking out for me for but then we
got into a very long interrogation
process he told me that there was a
Benedetto that didn't know me he wanted
F my name was really Benedetto and of
course I said I was he has to see my
wallet he went through my wallet was
going through my my dampener that uh ID
it led to a three-and-a-half hour
interrogation I mean a very good
interrogation that a detective would do
in doing so in the middle of the
interview I felt that there was one
person that could compromise me will be
Angelo pontine he was the power to be
behind the scenes at the wastepaper
association that was controlled by the
Genovese family Frank galino said to me
at one point Dan hold on I got it
someone's at the door waiting to see me
I'll be right back I looked back was
Angelo Ponte now his family's from
Krakow Italy where the Bennett that have
come from
he knew the band that I was in their
employees for years so this guy I knew
this is the worst night of my life
this guy would compromise me they'd ask
me questions that I wouldn't be able to
handle I mean I I have learned the
industry I had learned to walk the walk
and talk the talk but this was a angel
pond he was a very shrewd guy a very
smart guy a very good businessman and he
was the one guy that could really
shoot me down he came to the table with
frankly you know and a very tense very
very stressful the interrogation took
place and ultimately I got over I don't
know how they bought it yeah I guess
maybe they wanted to buy it I was able
to talk my way out of it and from that
point on I got very very close to Joe
Frankel II know through him I got close
to the Genovese captain or capo alle
shades and the Genovese who was control
to the associations but for the Genovese
family and that inside look was their
death knell that was it it's a long and
protracted investigation in your deep
undercover can you just describe for us
or walk us through what a typical day
was for you where you you know you have
this this family and you work for the
the NYPD but then you have to get into
your character and and what that was
like and what the day was like yes my
day I would get up about 5:30 in the
morning I'd drive to from my home as Ric
Cowan I would drive over to an apartment
building in Staten Island that was
switch cars I would drive the Chamber's
and I would collect all the dump tickets
I would go over the work that I had to
do as a garbage guy and young recycler I
would see that trucks were picking up
their stops when they were supposed to
and dealing with all kinds of all kinds
of situations and he tried to focus on
the police investigation as done to
cover and your job also as a recycler
running a transfer station but we had
four floors of tenants over the transfer
station and the wackiest most
unbelievable incidents would occur
throughout this case landlord tenant
disputes that I'd have these crazy
people screaming about this once doing
this and doing that and they're trying
to open up a nightclub and all these
kind of crazy things there was it was
all this unforeseen stuff going on all
the time but I would deal I would deal
with the the industry stuff there in a
day
I will get a phone calls from the
presidents of the Association were the
wise guys about getting together for
lunch
of course it would never say where the
lunch is certain days I knew where we
had a bay this is their very cryptic on
the phone because in case law
enforcement were listening to us I knew
where to go and we would have these
lunches that were turned into big mega
meals I mean none of these wise guys
miss any meals I mean they're all
healthy guys they can eat all day long
and I like to eat as you could see but I
could not keep up with these guys
we would go out to dinner we'd have a
nice dinner and the dinners we ate were
better than anybody else in the
restaurant
I mean he's Joe frankly no when he sat
down to eat did not order off the menu
they we had a guy just for us and like
Joe said to the waiter so you see my
friends glass it never gets empty I mean
we were the Kings
that's what's attractive to people in
these neighborhoods with these mob guys
it's a culture that won't die
it to some extent it will always be
there because these guys are worshipped
like you can't believe and it will
survive I mean the look that the level
of hoods are not what it used to be but
because of that culture these guys are
worshipped I so I got the experience of
full you know full force and it's
something to see so it'll be a long day
I would switch cars go to the transfer
station do the industry work meet the
wise guys meet the association's scheme
scam eat and drink and then I will go
home at night I would drive into the GUP
parking lot of the the place where I was
supposedly living now a park in the
basement garage I'll go out the back
door out the alleyway out onto the next
block where my Rick camel car was parked
get in it and go home the days were very
long and I would do this every day this
is a pattern of my activity I should I
should say one thing about what Rick did
that he's modest and on one level this
case was prosecuted in Manhattan Supreme
Court before a very famous judge named
Leslie Crocker Snyder and in writing
this book I had to call and I called a
few people who knew Rick and one of the
things Rick had to do in learning this
in this day-to-day life he had to master
this very complicated industry and when
I
call down to speak to the judges what's
is a Theresa Theresa the clerk she told
me a funny story about how here's the
judge these are you know legendary
jurist and with Ivy League degrees they
all had to learn the same economic
details of this case that Rick had to do
and Theresa the clerk told me you know
we were we were astounded but we were
confused we couldn't keep they had to
know everything Rick had learned so in
her one explanation of how he was able
to pull this off is he actually I'd to
become this other person and learn this
very complicated economic industry
luckily he had this guy Sal teaching him
but it boggles the mind and I've had to
go through all the tapes that he put me
made and you really err you're dealing
with some stuff that unless you grew up
in this industry you would wonder how
anyone could master it I mean it really
is not I think most typical Undercovers
have to play the role of a hang around
guy a guy who's on the street selling
drugs or doing doing bad things to be a
legitimate guy you have to really have a
believable story and what Rick did is
really it's not a very very much not a
typical undercover role and even even
the judge found hard to master what he
passed any other questions right off the
bat and yes please
clear wreck there's the business clean
now I'm gonna say that business is clean
I'm sure it's the the prices have come
down drastically there is competition
the people of the city and the
commercial establishments are paying on
a hell of a lot less than they were but
it would be naive to think that's
completely clean the mob is hard to get
rid of there's wise guys that had
partnerships and companies that are I'm
sure still trying to hold on to what
they had well what is different here in
this city now since the case ended is
with the NYPD had this large-scale
investigation that took down dismantled
the institutionalized monopolies that
the mafia had they're cartel system lock
stock and barrel controlled the carting
company owners the Union men the you the
company owners I mean they had it all
that that institutionalized system has
been taken down and is not functioning
now is there some criminality in the
garbage industry
would say yes but the but the control
that they had on everybody and the
astronomical pressures that they were
paying has come to an end
right now I mean there was something
called the trade waste Commission which
is largely they passed a law called
local law 42 largely I mean because of
this case if you go on the website today
there they will tell any businessman in
New York if you have a problem with your
carting if you want another if you want
a competitive bid and it's staffed by
organized crime detectives so there is
policing of this industry now and there
is competition which is a big change
from what there what it existed in the
past follow up ok I'm sorry you have to
wait wait for the microphone sorry I
think it was early this year reported
some mob activity at ground zero
that's demolition I mean there's there's
different aspects of garbage if you you
mean you have to know the details of the
industry but there are demolition
companies and yes they were mobbed-up
companies right hauling away scrap metal
yeah that was a scrap metal case that
was different than the garbage industry
or the recycling industry they were
taking some of the metal girders and
instead of going to a metal transfer
station they were diverting it to other
places stealing it so that was localized
it was isolated criminality not a cartel
system yes well let's say sorry good
some other people have questions first
can you do what you did and then return
to the police force and be comfortable
that there are no possible consequences
of what you did yeah I believe so
my career has changed significantly
since then the police departments taken
the precautions and regarding my
personal life and I am I'm working more
behind the scenes today than I used to
before the case not on the street a
month or undercover work certainly it
has curtailed my investigative duties
somewhat
okay for a second front row I have a
question about how careful these guys
are they evaded police everybody FBI for
a long long time for decades how did
they do that how good were they at
evading people these guys were very
sophisticated there are well schooled
gangsters know over the years with all
these criminal mafia trials over the
last 10 years you have to testify in
court
as that what how you did it and it you
educate them as you go along
they had yeah you listen to them on
phones and these kind of phones and cell
phones so you're educating the mob and
these Crimmins as you go along so they
were very very careful
like Jill frankly no said he called me
down to his office once and said to me
he hold up he took the phone off her
took the receiver off the phone held it
up I said this is Justin an ornament
just moved his mouth not the talk on the
phone if it's a Tuesday I got see it
you'll know where I mean if it's another
Friday Tuesday Thursday whatever I knew
where to see him this way law
enforcement wouldn't go set up on
location and capture our meetings and
that's how these guys were they did not
talk on the phone they were talking
about beefs they would not talk about
bid rigging and going down breaking guys
heads very seldom did they talk about
that on the telephone or even inside
places normally I would like one night
there was a very prominent garbage man
that ran afoul of Joe Frankel II know
this guy was around for decades there
was part of the mafia machine he took
some stops off some members of Joe Frank
le nose for for a number of reasons he
was given a warning that if he didn't
straighten it out and return the stops
that he would deal with Joe Franco Nino
and this guy was a chip off the old
block of John Gotti Franklin Hill told
me that if there's any defiance he could
be someone's best friend or he could be
the worst in the world it's better to
have 300 friends and one enemy there 300
enemies are one friend so he said that
message to these guys
they're a little slow getting the
message and he put them out of the
Association one night I went down to see
Joe as soon as you saw me I had missed
the meeting but I walked in I just come
back from being in Florida for a weekend
one of the few vacations if you want a
quote that I had there in this case and
he said let's take a walk we went out to
his Mercedes got some spine cigars we
walked down West Broadway with his front
veto be walking behind us all the way
down the block he said the five brothers
was put out of the Association they're
no longer members I want you to go after
him
go after him get it all you can off of
me so these very problems were put out
and these they very quickly returned
everything the way Joe Franklin you know
was but being he he made me and the
other guys in the club go after their
work they lost a lot of work that will
never be returned to them because they
were at that brief time outlaws and in
the way rules were they didn't have to
what they lost they lost they couldn't
get it back so that's how they
controlled carding companies it's what I
mean one thing that constantly happens
to Rick in the book is that guys pat him
down take apart his phone this was I
mean something of the Ivy League of
organized crime these guys were the most
sophisticated guys around if you're used
to seeing mob guys and movies acting
like big dummies these guys were very
sophisticated and they were very
conscious not to say stupid things if
you listen to the tape recordings if
you're expecting The Sopranos or
Goodfellas of that it's kind of criminal
talk where things are very explicit what
they'll say is that you know our friend
you know I saw the guy you know and it's
they do not say things openly and they
had to take Rick on sort of walk and
talks all the time so I mean the
question of like how they were the most
conscious probably mob guys around
because they were working in a very
legitimate environment and they were
very conscious that they didn't want to
get caught saying something stupid okay
front did you ever hear the wiseguys
justify what they were doing mmm because
you know you can make even if it's
specious a case that consolidating
certain industries makes things run more
efficiently do they
we're tell themselves stories like that
these guys had this system had gone on
so long they believe there's all
legitimate they they thought it was okay
to do what they were doing they thought
they were saving like he told me oh
we're just doing this to save legal fees
but that's not it there is no legitimate
reason to do what they did they were
charging people for five times and even
more times the legal rate well 55 Water
Street right over here is one of the
largest commercial establishments in the
country a huge building probably second
to the World Trade Center they were paid
they were paying like a like a $100,000
a month another company came in and did
it for nine thousand a month this is the
this is how they're being overcharged
there is no excuse legitimately for that
comparison yeah they caught they would
tell themselves that yeah one of the
things that's very funny about how they
justified this Rick's the company Rick
was working with was a legitimate
company but in the mob world that's an
outlaw I mean they really considered
themselves legitimate and if you were
independent and competing you're an
outlaw and they keep saying you're an
outlaw you're branded an outlaw these
are criminals but yeah they had
obviously had done it for so many years
that if you were living by like the free
enterprise system which is legitimate in
America you were doing the wrong thing
there are other hands up yes at the back
it sounds like this case was really
all-consuming were there ways are times
where it overlapped into your personal
life yes there were a lot of times I ran
into these guys is Rick Cowen when they
knew me as Dan Benedetto there was some
fleeting moments I would pull up on my
car written you know that comes back
there Rick Cowen but I would see guys
from the club that know me as Dan
Benedetto I easily drove away but there
was another time my son was only about
three months old I was my wife in Staten
Island
in the Santa Ana mall any we have a new
baby you're very protective you're very
close to the baby and I'm at the helm
with the stroller and pushing my son to
my son my wife's right next to me and as
I'm approaching Sears I see a guy coming
at me who's a prominent member of
frankly knows club and he
dumps his paper waste at my transfer
station so I don't want to bring that
whole thing into the rick allen life so
i as soon as I saw him I took a stage
left I went through some miles of
OshKosh B'gosh clothes and I tried to
see where he was going but of course my
wife did see any of this I took off so
fast so she's looking all around I'm
seeing it the guys around and I waited
for about a half an hour until I got out
of the the Isles of clothing and found
my wife again and at that time I'd have
to worry about gangsters she was more
mad than they would have been she was
gonna kill me
she did want to hear anything you buy
soy I say this oil guy in the case is a
hell with the case I'm tired of hearing
that but does she want to kill me but
there was a lot of this is like then in
the third row yes now now that it's it's
over how hard was it for you to go back
to being Rick Cowen that's the first
part and the second part is if you
didn't already when are you gonna take
your wife on a nice romantic vacation
friend of my wife's the undoubtedly yes
it was difficult was a difficult
transition getting back leaving that
damn banner that a role I was coming
back into doing you know police work I
was testifying before a grand jury for
several months when supposedly I was in
Chicago but really I was in in New York
before a grand jury testifying three
days a week it was very difficult I had
this whole all these people that I know
some bid a lot of bad people but there
were some good people too when it's all
said and done we've got this book thing
pass this I will take my wife out on a
very nice trip but you know it was the
same thing now I got to know some good
people in the industry that know me as
Dan Benedetto I would have liked to have
had the opportunity to tell him what I
was doing I mean they believed me hook
line and sinker they came to me for all
kinds of reasons believing I was really
damn Benedetto when I had to leave
suddenly and not see these people
there's a whole handful of them that
unfortunately have passed away and it
made it even more difficult to
transition that it then
it should have been Rick Cowen is a 20
year veteran of the New York City Police
Department
Douglas century is a contributing editor
at the forward newspaper take down the
fall of the last muffin Pierre is
published by GP Putnam's sons a division
of penguin Putnam for more information
visit penguin Putnam com